[Music]
that's one possibility
meantime down down here there's a queen
check but the knight can retreat and
block the check so for the moment ant
know he's and anticipate more cautiously
if that's possible in this position he's
prevented the Queen check but he's more
to be taken ring is magnificent
sacrifice he's looking to checkmate with
the battery of the rook in the queen
look at this checkmate so he's looking
to swing the rook across and then Queen
down checkmate now let's have a look at
her ground shook he's slowed up now just
over two minutes left and Anand about
three minutes left a fine shot looking
worried he certainly could have couldn't
have predicted that one and that rook a
crucial move because it's preventing the
bishop coming back checking as well look
at the advantage of biting his finger
and he's now under two minutes and now
he's brought his rookie to the game look
at this rook move and he's looking to go
on the counter-attack he just looking to
make some kind of a sacrifice on the
White King and that would just bust open
a position an amazing game with these
twists and turns and black proving
resourceful here it looked as if my 9
had real mating chances but if magic
fighting back heavily I think that's a
great move if rook if the rook swings
across to h3 threatening mate then rook
takes pawn check King takes rook and
then swing then the next rook across
rook to see a check and that looks like
a lethal counter-attack because then
after that after that sacrifice black's
queen would enter the attack and that
would surely be decisive
so now Anand has a very tricky decision
to make
does he continue the attack or does he
take to spend one move trying to defend
I think if he goes on the defensive it
could be all over for dad last what now
was extremely powerful he's under two
minutes has one minute 55 left for all
his moves and I was gonna have to
survive he has a very little time to
think about all of this
so does not his time has gone and he has
before he has allowed this astonishing
rook sacrifice note anon is threatening
devastation in one move clean down check
make game over so advantage gonna have
to go for it he's gone for has Oh an
amazing sacrified our rook is coming to
the game now Anand must find an exact
path for his King if he if he finds if
he goes to the wrong square it'll just
be checkmate
for instance if King up Queen takes a
night check and well that looks deadly
or King here Queen takes pawn check
please play the King to the back rank
running amazing now Queen check King up
what's going on here rook check maybe
couldn't bring the knight back Wow would
be amazing that King with two bishops
and a rook and a queen after it and that
King looks as if it's still dancing and
the King has moved up even more now the
Queen come oh that looks very nasty
indeed the Queen coming back checking
the King if King takes then the rook
rook comes down mate rook check Oh
busted it looks as if he's gonna be made
it is a nun where can he go he's backed
his king up Queen check that's gotta be
it
surely its mate why can't he just take
the he could take the rook in the corner
what is Queen the Queen takes for a mate
that is net game that look only in the
fan trip short he's not gonna lose his
that he glasses the clock he doesn't
speak three second isn't she this is
unbelievable
Queen takes rook I'm missing something
Queen takes rook in the corner is check
me and he doesn't see it any as map is
listed unbelievable that is astonishing
that a grand master of advisor Excalibur
night one and now the night has come
back a nice now he's got 40 seconds Oh
under the time prize running waiting
this is unbelievable that's almost
unheard of in a chess game this is
incredible in a non now looking for his
own chance and he's rushed the porn look
at this guy this is incredible the Queen
check incredible this check the King
going in the corner this is just
extraordinary and Avant rock
he's not he's got the piece back he's
got one piece back but he's still a
whole rook down this is still highly
unclear Queen check threatened and then
mate I think you'll spot it the second
time around
Queen check threatened and queen mate
but it looks like Queen evite is
possible what about decentralized and
Queens I think he's done he's you don't
move
protecting everything and now imagine
with a rook check gotta be frightened
here and now a quitting chick he's
continuing his attack he's continuing
the play down the board now King up and
then the Queen can just swing back take
the point he's gone into the center look
at the time seconds one side twenty
seconds for the other they're gonna just
have to fly with the moves and ejecting
randomly and only with 13 seconds on his
blocking invite is an honest back up and
in font of checking again he only has
nine seconds on his clock you'll never
make it then he's short he needs he
needs to stop the game oh holy that
sanic slackens unbelievable anon with
twenty seconds he's moved his king up
and now he's trying to repeat move the
kids born up another check four seconds
a lot oh but this is close he might not
survive 90 for two seconds Oh a check he
must be only one second and his his time
is over
[Music]
Oh